[Music]
[Applause]
so hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
as you just saw the new recognition
emote came out and in a non-biased
fashion --gel ideator has the best one
yet this is probably the best emote he's
ever had and it just fits his character
so well him being a Coliseum type
gladiator and having the crowd chant and
his background and stuff like that I
just think it goes really well
especially with the rep 60 effect this
little sulfuric spark I just think it
looks absolutely insane incredibly
stunning so yeah as usual with these
type of things we're gonna be doing a
couple duels showing it off stuff like
that and let's get into that right now
we have a gladiator for this game let's
see how he plays I thrown out heavy you
know he thrown out them heavy faints
real quick I respect it figured that was
going to be a big parry
she's gonna whip out that heavy we're
good toast that all good stuff I was
getting a little cocky there I was
fighting him a little bit too much you
know being a little aggressive I need to
pull back a bit let him do him and then
just counter his stuff that that -
forward
the sucker punch was definitely a really
stupid idea especially after the heavy
follow-up that was not gonna get me
anywhere so let's see if I can make
something out of this good heavy parrot
just start off the mat or a good life
parry to start off totally caught me on
that poof yeah alright he try to go for
that parry didn't work I see you I see
what you're doing buddy
caught you again on that Oh got me and
the heavy Perry once again man's got it
down we'll end it with that well choke
him out for the execution that was a
close fight man's is getting really good
at pairing those lights I have to start
following those up but it's going to be
a one-sided match isn't gonna be good
throw it down hopefully it stands
[Music]
I'll regime see that's the only issue is
that the devs need to design emotes so
that they're long enough when the
victory screen comes up because the same
thing with the Kamehameha and then this
one they're both not they're both good
emotes like don't get me wrong they're
definitely good emotes they're not long
enough so we can't see the whole thing
and that's the issue
Oh Big D flight good stuff did I [ __ ]
sound cut out from that oh he got me he
absolutely destroyed me this game I was
doing too many stupid things during that
flight good flight did I still have
enough time to come back for this though
so I'm not stressing about it
he knows the light pit he knows the
parry timings as hopefully most people
should of the side - light so I need to
not use those as much I do a lot more
faints try to try to throw lights but
only when I think they're gonna be
guaranteed or this is going to
completely and brutally screw me over so
that's not good
a little toast AB in there
and we'll get them with a quick one
there see you just have to play against
you basically have to counter what the
other person is doing and then you'll
start succeeding so I stopped doing I
did I did one move that was a very risky
but I stopped doing the side dash lights
because I knew that he would get those
timings down so I just completely
stopped them and I was just bad timing
right there you if he would have thrown
if I knew he was gonna throw a second
light I would have parried that that
have been really good well I had no
intention of carrying that I didn't
think that was going to be even a thing
that he was gonna throw give me that
good zone thanks bud
try not to lose my stamina here even
though he cooked me with that oh that
might be gg no that'll be a heavy that's
not gonna kill me just yet
this Waldo good flight part-time I
respected dude so one of the things that
I noticed from that last section there
is even when you're low on health you
can't be freaking out he wanted to throw
that he saw that move coming he's like
imma throw this guard break see if I can
catch him that's not a good thing you
want to get your stamina back as quick
as possible because obviously it's just
a guard breaking especially cuz you're
out of stamina your moves are slower
guard breaks are super easy to notice
like anybody can counter guard break and
out of stamina one so that was his
problem and that means he stopped his
stamina regain while I kept going I got
my thing up he fell for the toe stab
except I was gonna throw the toe step
but if the regarde break threw him back
for the technically out of stamina the
full out of stamina thing but I decided
to just whip out the move because I was
a little bit low but GG's on that let's
get into the next game next match we
have a rep and 9 Raider now I've never
been really good at fighting Raiders the
full heavy the side heavy is too slow
that move is too slow for my guard and
will actually my guard will actually run
out which is not good so any character
that can throw moves like that is just
an absolute kryptonite to me me
personally not sure about any other just
I'm not sure about any gladiators of
them me but it's mostly just me you saw
that coming see I had to double up on
that guard just in case next stunning
tap will try to parry it because that is
gonna cost me some health if he keeps
doing that probably guess in the next
move have you faintness tonic tap couple
double lights not bad
it's up just a few lights I was trying
to throw a couple zones but control our
inputs and stuff making you throw
heavies and lights instead of zones
usually happens if you play on a
controller you know what I'm talking
about
so I meant to throw a zone actually on
that last move but end up working out
really well
and I started being a lot more passive
and not too aggressive because ended up
throwing the zone and I didn't even move
I just let the zone go and I knew
because I had a feeling that wasn't
gonna hit me because I was right within
those that range so I didn't want to do
that he's just gonna throw all these out
of me thanks bud a little fake of the
guard break completely intended I guess
but that only net me a heavy because I
don't want to run out of stamina doing
moves like that especially against
Raider quick having to parry draining a
bit she's finished with an easy light
throughout the X throw out the new emote
as well it's not gonna finish though
[Music]
sadness it's all I asked man there's a
few things I asked about this game and
one important thing in game mechanic
wise is just make emotes short enough or
long but make them short enough so that
they can at least try to fit in the dual
screen that can ruin some of the that
might ruin some emotes like feature you
months that they might have but that's
all I want cuz I want to be able to
throw it and yo use it you know mid game
and not have to like have a cut out so
we're both out of stamina here he's got
the win in terms of health the moment
I'm gonna try to lower that a bit a good
stunning tat parry would be perfect
right now
can't catch these lights dude [ __ ]
[Music]
wellgood Perry oh you went for the
follow up I was not expecting the follow
up heavy after the stunning tap I was
just assuming he was gonna throw the
stunning tap afterwards and that was it
which caught me cuz I was trying to
throw the car break-in up getting me but
it's okay cuz I'm up to one I'll have to
do is win one game he has to win two in
a row so I'm not stressing about this at
all see if I could pull off a few other
moves maybe get around that or next time
make sure to watch out for what he's
gonna throw because you never know try
to go for that guard break bail saucy
give me the hell light I was close and
very close where's backup meant to do
his own didn't connect the course good
Harry that's gonna hurt me
I'm low on stamina so I don't want to
risk too much but I'm just gonna get
that I'm just gonna get some decent
damage out of that one what I'd like to
do is when I don't have a lot of stamina
I just do a light in the top heavy
instead of doing a like the full move oh
that's gonna cook me dude
see once again with the controller input
I wanted to throw a zone and that
probably would have killed him but my
controller said nah and you're just
gonna throw a light so that [ __ ] me a
little bit but it's alright I'll try to
come back I don't see why I can't win
this I have a very confident in this
fight
I'm just small minor mistakes quick
heavy to start this match
I just can't fall for stuff catch these
lights when they come by if you check if
you've replayed that scene and check my
guard and went it went right through it
because of shitty guards because of cuz
of glad shitty get reflex guard that
costed me that heavy just replayed I
swear to god I hate it it's one of the
few things I hate about this character
wow that should have been a parry also
waiting on that oh dude
through it a bit too late I thought it
was on target a third a bit late good
fight man I I definitely made a few
mistakes there didn't do the controller
input good enough I threw a few moves
that should have been zones Bend up
being lights that's a big issue
I don't know I'm assuming that happens
everybody else does not just me
and then an obvious obviously just not
pairing his lights and whatnot so
obviously you want to come out of every
single game that you play figuring out
why you lost in certain things that you
catch the do your own mistakes so that
you can improve on them and later fights
and that's what I do every time I play
this but yeah guys that's gonna be the
end of the videos I hope you guys did
enjoy it like I said all you always want
to do is just come make any oh just make
sure that you learn from your mistakes
kind of salt it and beat that Raider I
totally should have had that game 3 oh
but he just got the better of me in that
last portion I don't know if it was
cockiness or something like that but
either way go fights the bolt that guys
hopefully guys do enjoy the emo person
like I said
gladiator as you can see best emote the
crowds chanting forum it's crazy just
wish it was a little bit shorter so that
I could use it during the victory screen
and stuff like that but yeah I'm excited
let me you guys know what your favorite
emote is of this bunch if you've bought
in it if you've not bought it but it's
gonna be 7000 steel so if you haven't
definitely go check that out one that
guys you guys watch the video I like the
view do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational side I'm
foreigner that being downstate is here
are updates patch notes leaks all that
[ __ ] with some gladiator gameplay
involved as well all that good stuff
I'm with that guys my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out and that guy's so
very great yesterday thank you for
watching the video and peace out
[Music]